the District Attorney prosecuting three
white defendants in the killing of a
black man says she sees a family and a
community that are broken AM out our
bure was shot to death in February
apparently while jogging in his
neighborhood outside Brunswick Georgia
Gregg and Travis McMichael and William
rowdy Bryan have all pleaded not guilty
Cobb County Georgia DA joy at Holmes is
the fourth prosecutor to be put in
charge of the case
Omar Villafranca spoke with Holmes for
48 hours in her first Network TV
interview can you walk us through what
happened that day as you've seen it I
think that evidence will speak for
itself when we get in court I've been
very intentional and purposeful and
making sure that this case from our
perspective gets tried in the courtroom
public opinion is important but it's not
what leads the day have you seen the
video I have seen it yeah can you
believe that that something like this
still happens in this day and age
unfortunately yes the McMichaels and
Bryan faced nine charges including four
counts of felony murder a judge from a
different part of Georgia has been
assigned to the case a trial date has
not been set yet gale yeah I love that
the prosecutors being very clear about
we're gonna take this out of the court
of public opinion and have it be tried
in the courts where it let the facts
fall where they may in this case but the
video is always very disturbing